revenir sur les mesures phares prises
par donald trump
c'est un peu la première décision de joe
biden dans le bureau ovale il a signé 17
décret présidentiel
ils doivent permettre à la nouvelle
administration de faire face aux crises
multiples que traversent les états unis
certaines des mesures exécutif que je
vais signer aujourd'hui vont contribuer
à inverser le cours de la crise du coc
vide et nous allons combattre le
changement climatique comme nous ne
l'avons jamais fait jusqu'ici et faire
progresser les kits et raciales et
soutenir les autres communautés mal
desservies
nous allons également reconstruire notre
économie pour lutter contre la
propagation du coc u19 qui a fait plus
de 400 morts dans le pays
joe biden a rendu obligatoire le port du
masque dans les bâtiments fédéraux une
agence rattachée à la maison blanche
doit désormais coordonner l'action
sanitaire contre le coronavirus en
pleine pandémie son arrivée à la maison
blanche marque également le retour des
états unis au sein de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
donald trump s'en était retiré en mai
dernier
il l'accusait d'avoir mal géré la crise
du coronavirus autre mesure phare elle
concerne la politique en matière de
changements climatiques
joe biden y souhaitent rejoindre
l'accord de paris d'ici à un mois
donald trump s'était retiré de cet
accord peu après son investiture
enfin le 46e président des états unis
met fin à la construction et au
financement du mur à la frontière avec
le mexique une construction engagés par
donald trump coup d'arrêt également à un
décret migratoire controversé le muslim
ban
il interdisait aux ressortissants de
pays en majorité musulman d'entrée aux
états unis
m